how would you advise someone
communicates now moving forward in a
productive manner do you have
a way that you try and do that
um don't be a hero
because these people are on edge uh
there's blood in the water and they
they will come for you you know they'll
do as much damage to your life as they
can and they'll feel justified in doing
it
um they they will ruin you if if they
can
so don't be a hero um
but if it's something that's really
bothering you and you you feel
tremendously motivated to do something
there are lots of um
people who are trying to push back in
lots of different ways
and you can do your part by like you
know buying their book or buying you
know the t-shirt or whatever it is that
they're doing to
finance themselves because competition
to the moral worldview that's being
presented in black lives matter and
anti-far
is being attacked you know it's just
being attacked for being
in opposition to this at this point so
you
th these people definitely need support
but it is also worth
um trying to go
past the idea of police reform because
essentially you can be like well there
are many ways to skin a cat
right like i might i might want police
reform too but i don't think defunding
the police is the way to get police
reform
so i'm gonna you know i have a different
idea for that which might be
and i mean there are lots of ideas like
in america something like 70
of the police don't police their own
districts that they live in so they're
from out of town that have come
that's you know that's you can see why
that would be a concern right
so you might want police reform so it's
like you know 70 percent do police their
own districts or something like that you
know
so there are other ways to get um to to
resolve
issues and there are issues to be
resolved um
but i guess you know you just have to
have these
very difficult conversations if you want
but you'll probably get disavowed very
[Music]
quickly
you